foreign
I know a lot of women are insecure about
the downstairs area but hold on a second
this
one right here that you have
it's just unbelievably beautiful
this guy
a few examples of how you can worship
your partner's [__] you can take one of
these things and do it or you can
combine a few or even all of the
examples that I'm going to give you in
one [__] worship ritual I mean [__]
number one is [__] gazing simply look
at your partner's [__] and
hey we call that perven
you want to worship the [__] look at
the partner's [__] just look at it
[__] gazing stare at it it doesn't
matter if you're in public they have a
skirt and get lower [__] look at it
getting inside her a way to worship it
thrusting in and out splurting splurt
Sport and we're splurting and there we
go right
thinking of other women when you're
inside a [__] think of another [__]
beautiful powerful and healing things
that you can do especially because so
many women experience a lot of
insecurities about how the evolva vagina
and [__] looks like imagine that dude
how insecure you'd be after that guy
saying that to you
that's why I like to go wow that is just
absolutely beautiful you know what you
might be insecure about that but boy I
gotta tell you that's beautiful that's
what I do
that's what I do as soon as I see it for
the first time too I did it to my wife
that's how I got her
I say
yo whoa whoa hold on a second
what is going on there that is beautiful
sweetie
sweetie doll that is a beautiful
beautiful beautiful part on you
being an expression tell her how
beautiful her [__] is tell her how
delicious she tastes
imagine going down there and just being
like hold on hold on a second hold on
stop the cap that is gorgeous that
tastes gorgeous hold on a second stop
the cap that tastes good sweetie sweetie
doll stop the cap
you're insecure about this sweetie doll
this is unbelievable this is just great
sweetie doll
hello how wonderful she smells oh you
smell great sweetie this is amazing
that's me another wonderful way to of
course touch your party and feel the
depth of love and gratitude God this
feels great this just feels absolutely
fantastic me during doing it during
intercourse
now I don't know why you're insecure
about this but God does this feel good
that's me during intercourse life-giving
pleasure giving Source let's make a baby
a tips of your fingers as you are
touching her as you are giving her
pleasure touch her playfully in a way
that explores another another tip to do
[__] worship
like you mean it ow Dude Perfect
eat her like you mean it dude that is
100 if that's not an R B song
girl
I'mma eat you like I mean it
girl a lot of guys just be laughing imma
be eating it like I mean it
you turn like it's the most delicious
meal you've ever I mean don't chew it
you know tasted your entire life
don't eat her because you have to don't
eat her because you try to make her eat
her
Dahmer
um don't eat her because you think she
would like it eat her because it's the
most erotically alive the most desirable
and the most pleasurable thing that you
can do and lastly and especially if you
are spiritually oriented sure in your
life is to really perform an elaborate
ritual involving worshiping your power
hey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I don't know why you're insecure about
that it feels absolutely amazing the
house is on fire god damn it baby get
out get out put your clothes on and get
out no skip the clothes get out run to
the neighbors
is [__] it can be something along the
line of your partner sitting at the
middle of a circle of flowers you know
for example you can light candles and
nonsense and you see them meditate in
front of her vagina you can offer some
flowers fruits or sweets and the
greatest part about this you can do this
on the subway around
our offerings for the goddess as well as
incorporate everything that feels
creative yeah and joyful and playful and
fun for you to incorporate in that
ritual after you from that kind of
ritual you can also take that and
incorporate everything else that I've
spoken about and perform any of these
things as a part of the ritual I come on
sweetie doll let me tell you know what
I'm gonna perform that there we don't
mess up the circle of flowers but sit
right here
okay now let me start this here fire
there we go I'm getting my big banana
leaf here we go let me just touch it see
that's wet see now the deal with that is
it feels amazing right I don't know why
I know sometimes the thing to do if
you're a woman and you've got you know a
lot of women are into but the way this
one feels is just absolutely Bonker City
oh my God
sweetie doll I'm gonna eat it let me eat
it and let me just see what this is oh
my God
well hello
that is the greatest thing I could do
for me
hey I
I I now I'm just gonna add more all
right the house is on fire get out see
ya dude but that's that's worshiping it
I don't think honestly you should
worship uh anything crazy crazy
crazy crazy congratulations
[Music]